vimos las marchas en contra del talibán
multiplicarse en varias ciudades de
afganistán incluida kabul la capital y
vimos también la bandera tricolor afgana
convertida en un símbolo en contra de
los insurgentes que ondean en su
tradicional bandera blanca encontrará
entonces el talibán una resistencia real
por parte de la ciudadanía en su opinión
buenas noches diana sí claro mira lo va
a encontrar definitivamente lo va a
encontrar porque cuando nosotros vemos
está este retorno talibán es diferente
al de hace 20 años me parece que la
ciudadanía va va a efectuar una pasiva o
una manifestación más activa pero sí va
a encontrar una resistencia el talibán
bueno pero por otro lado el talibán ha
mostrado una imagen moderada de cara al
exterior pero en afganistán ya
comenzamos a ver represión muertes y
abusos a los derechos de la mujer
principalmente cómo quedan las
expectativas entonces de la comunidad
internacional que hoy por ejemplo
hablaba de presionar por la creación de
un gobierno inclusivo es esto posible
cree usted que se acabará entonces por
ceder y reconocer el gobierno de los
talibanes
mira
definitivamente sí va a haber
reconocimiento creo que incluso pakistán
por la misma posición geopolítica
no nos extraña que sea uno de los
primeros que el que lo haga pero no cabe
engañarnos por esos gestos aparentemente
moderados ya sea que estén ofreciendo
esa es a esa moderación y colaboración
con otros porque es lo que están
tratando es de manifestarse
internacionalmente y que no vean esa
situación común como han empezado a
darse señalamientos respecto a las
violaciones por ejemplo de los derechos
humanos pero sí creo que puede haber una
una una estable tratar de tener una
estabilización no va a ser fácil es para
para ellos a pesar de que puedan mandar
señales de
y moderación pero si van a haber países
que si nos van a reconocer bueno y es
que la toma del poder por parte del
talibán genera todo tipo de temores a
nivel internacional no sólo de seguridad
sino también en materia migratoria
escuchemos por ejemplo lo que dijo el
presidente turco recep tayib erdogán
surgen en
el deber la responsabilidad y la
obligación de ser la unidad de
almacenamiento de migrantes de europa
una vez que cerremos fuertemente
nuestras fronteras
y enviamos a los actuales migrantes
irregulares a casa les corresponde a
ellos decidir a dónde irán civiles y
turistas pues volvemos con el profesor
guillermo pacheco para preguntarle por
la declaraciones que acabamos de
escuchar el presidente de turquía recep
tayib erdogán cuales cree usted que
serán las consecuencias de términos
migratorios que dejará esta crisis en
afganistán y qué posición deberían tomar
las naciones de la región frente al
inminente éxodo de ciudadanos afganos
mira definitivamente como lo vimos en
los días anteriores que evidentemente va
a haber una población grande que va a
tratar de salir de afganistán y va a dar
se mira aunque no lo querramos va a
darse un exceso de migración saliendo y
definitivamente van a haber países que
se van a ver afectados al respecto ya
europa hoy día hoy en la reunión que
tuvo
los gobiernos de europa están
posicionándose al respecto y creo que la
posición de turquía adelanta también
algunos posicionamientos de que no van a
poder digamos abrir de la manera como lo
como lo quisieran pero recordemos que
muchas veces está esta esta migración no
no respeta los trámites normales y me
parece que está esta inmigración de de
afganos saliendo de este proceso es sólo
el comienzo de lo que estamos viendo
ahora